[музика]
вона буряки будуть у центрі у вас і
поліпро їзди до брюсселя
олег тоні не Петро йому та й політику щодо
столиця чіп послаблюється і зайти на
еблище муна abbott йому для неї син
через що назар свого роду hop anno
перебуваючи в центрі біля води та надій людей
ці хоче прям ах ти тату листя
думаю у неї все ще багата при кліку
збагатив європейських країн європейського
у Європі та заткнув та splash вони поліції
і надягли ультра правому популіст у нор
бортів і руб не вдалося і прям ах ти на
президентських виборах в австрії о 9
ставка прем'єра італії маттео ренці
після провального рефрену будинку що в х і
краї надаможили виходу рядкових виборів
чого прогнути італійські популісти
теж хто нині і партнери світ колю європі
одним знай одягнеш їх поважаєте світлі
прем'єра соціал-демократ Стефан Левен
печатка щура біженців тут же Петро ім його
в канцлер комусь і позицію ще до
справедливо курс у справах біженців з
всієї Європи потім шива та ціни
політичний ваш кого ви сама мусата
вальсу європі якира нижчою будуть
складний їм право популістський ряд мої
поштою у нідерландах доступних уроку
вибором ми самі популісти може стати статуями
найса не шию партії україни
прем'єр-міністр іспанії маріано рахою
з наречених із проблем консервативний
політику в лояльний донеччини друк
криза євро дозволяють на популярно
курить акушерську бюджетну економію
половинки рою редмейн 6, то залежить вигляд
опозиції не повинен перший партнер
прем'єр-міністру зіпсований віктор орбан
зручні популісти Європи у вирішенні
проблем я українець з створення парку ні в
чим не пускати і біженців то
глобалізацію та типу малки роблять великі
європейської партії та викравши chuwi
реальний webmin астемир лівими та правими
саме з вини на магате себе за перед
втц
і роботи вигляд ще я лише демократи і
не демократи суті
від же з ви ікла я бо трохи албін 6
люди ще або ти об'єднатися проти
реальних людей та особи файли office
fighting був люди
дочка укуси виробляти ми вже побачила
але одному прикладі коли Великобританія
сказала не Європі британії було
політичної ваш кого ви кому якщо
називаєте нас аптечки годину на годину у Лондон
в сасш так і бу виважуємо союзну
камбар нам особливо рахунок економічних
намагай
people feel what i let уточнив далі
люди випивають
або ти не вражають традиційні цінності
патріотизм віру авторитет політична
коректність
зайшла на те далеко думав ви не голосують
прикладом як за марин ле пен
у Франції люди як його впоперек він вони
все через джинси риба приводу тис
джордж і ж крім людей від цієї як усі
кандидати вид консерватори франсуа фійон
пари можемо ангела Меркель могла б
заткнути з польші ним при ньому не
у харчування до європейської політики фійону
приходили до ліберальної економіки та
вірити в німецьку французьку
партнерством як плотику драма європа
розум і роботі та стабільну і ми вірні
доступний термін плавно важливий концерт
не мачин і будда на без різаки
особливо куллі ма увійди про європейську
політику
[музика]